ใช่
ตอนที่มองดูความสามารถในวันนี้ ผมคิดว่ามีคำถามสำคัญมากที่ต้องถามว่า
แล้วแผนการพัฒนาในอนาคตเป็นอย่างไร
ระบบพวกนี้จะดีขึ้นแค่ไหน
มันดีขึ้นได้มากแค่ไหน
และ circuit ที่ซับซ้อนแค่ไหน
ที่เราจะสามารถรันได้
สำหรับเรื่องนั้น เราได้พัฒนาตัวชี้วัดที่สำคัญมาก
ที่เรียกว่า quantum volume
บางทีในสื่อทั่วไปอาจจะได้อ่านหรือได้ยิน
เรื่องจำนวน qubit และ
ใช้มันเป็นตัววัดความก้าวหน้า
ขอบอกตรงๆ เลยว่า
แค่จำนวน qubit ในเครื่องไม่ใช่
ตัววัดความก้าวหน้าที่ดี
ความก้าวหน้าต้องวัดจาก
ระดับความซับซ้อนของ circuit ที่สามารถรันได้
qubit และเครื่องพวกนี้ยังไม่สมบูรณ์แบบในวันนี้
มันมีข้อผิดพลาดที่เกิดจากการที่ระบบ
ถูกรบกวนจากโลกภายนอก
พลังอันยิ่งใหญ่ของ qubit เหล่านี้
ทั้งเรื่อง entanglement และคุณสมบัติต่างๆ
ทำให้มันทั้งทรงพลัง
และบอบบางต่อการรบกวนจากภายนอก
และการเชื่อมต่อกับโลกภายนอก
ดังนั้นต้องลดอัตราข้อผิดพลาด
ในขณะที่เพิ่มจำนวน qubit ขึ้นด้วย
นั่นคือสิ่งที่แสดงในแผนภาพนี้
ถ้าอยากทำให้สำเร็จจริงๆ ต้องเดินในทิศทางแนวทแยง
และ quantum volume คือตัววัดที่รวม
ทั้งสองตัวชี้วัดนั้น และปัจจัยสำคัญอื่นๆ เข้าไว้ด้วยกัน